Hi. You Muslim?
>> I'm good, thanks. So, I was Yeah,
absolutely.
>> So, previously you've mentioned
previously you've mentioned that God is
going to come down with thousands of
saints, right? Can you go to the uh
Deuteronomy?
>> Brother, this this this isn't my topic.
My topic is that
>> No, that is your topic. I will address
it.
>> My Do you see the topic? Beautiful.
Beautiful. I need you to calm down.
>> I will I will prove
>> I need you to calm down, brother. I need
you to calm down. If you want to stay on
the stage and you want to get to your
argument, which I have no problem
getting to,
>> I you gotta first address the topic and
then we can go to Deuteronomy 33:2 and
talk about what you want to talk about.
I promise. Okay.
>> Right.
>> All right. [snorts] So, first of all,
would you trust a religion? Would you
trust a religion with a corrupted
scripture?
>> No, absolutely not.
>> You sure?
>> You So, yeah.
>> Okay. Do you believe?
>> I absolutely wouldn't trust it.
>> Okay. Do you believe that uh the Torah
was revealed by Allah?
>> Absolutely. 100%. I can prove it. I can
literally prove it to you.
>> No, it's okay. I'll take your word for
it.
>> 100% prove it to you,
>> brother. Brother, I'll take your word
for it.
>> So, go to the
>> brother. I need you I need you to listen
to me instead of having a debate in your
head. Listen. Listen to me.
>> I'll take your word for it. You don't
have to show me. Okay. The [snorts]
Torah is revealed by Allah. I'll take
it. That's what you believe. No problem.
Okay. Now, do you believe that the Torah
has been corrupted?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. What about the uh the Zabor, the
Psalms? Is [clears throat] that was that
revealed by Allah?
>> The whom? the zabore to David.
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> Okay. Was that corrupted as well?
>> Yes.
>> All right. What about um what about the
gospel? The
>> Bible and the next and the next David.
All of them are corrupted product. All
of them. Every single one of them is
corrupted. You don't need to go one by
one.
>> Okay. I got you. So all of Allah's
scriptures have been corrupted.
>> Yes.
>> Including the
>> And I can give you the reason of why
that is. Right. I can give you the
reason of why that is. You don't need
to.
>> You master some patience.
>> You don't you don't need to. I I don't I
don't my the reason why they were
corrupted is is not my not my
contention. Just that they were
corrupted. That's that's perfectly fine
with me. Okay. So, all of Allah's
revelations were corrupted. Hold on. I
got you.
>> So, and you're a Muslim. You you believe
in the religion of Islam?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> So, then this what you just said
>> is that all of the scriptures within
Islam are corrupted. So, Islam is
untrustworthy.
>> When I said they are corrupted, why?
Mhm.
>> Well, first of all, you're you're a very
rat person, right? You're you're acting
like a bloody rat, right? You said,
>> but you know well that you're acting
like a rat because you know well that we
have literal chapters in Quran dedicated
to all of these books and so yet you act
like a fool pretending to be a fool when
you know it well. I'm a beautiful.
>> That's your right nature.
>> Bro, I'm beautiful.
>> One second. Calm down, man. I'm
beautiful to you, right?
>> I'm beautiful. Come to you. One second,
man. Yeah. Yeah. Now you're starting to
like, you know, go wild. Chimping out.
Well, you say the guy whether is
Muhammad mentioned previously asked the
guy where what is Muhammad mentioned in
the
>> I had to mute you because for some
reason you are just in total bot mode
and you cannot engage and have a
conversation with the actual person like
you're really a bot. It's really amazing
to see. It's amazing to see you guys
come up and go into straight bot mode.
Stop being a bot. engage with the person
that's talking to you, please. I
appreciate
>> you. You don't make a point. You just
pushing.
>> So, do so. Do you agree that the script
that Islam is untrustworthy? Cuz you
said it has corrupted scriptures in it.
>> There are scriptures, but they are
corrupted. What part of it do you not
understand? When you worship, you're an
idoltor. You don't have to ask me. You
have to go ask me. Relax.
>> They say that he's in me. Relax, bro.
Relax.
You don't got to cuss at me. You guys
didn't You guys hear that? He cussed at
me in Arabic or whatever that language
was. You don't got to cuss at me. Okay.
You You yourself said
>> define idolatry. Define idolatry. I will
prove it. You disrupt it. Define idol.
>> My my bad, bro. I I cut you off. Go
ahead. And like you were making your
point. I didn't want to cut you off. Go
ahead.
>> So, yes. Yes. Fantastic. Thank you very
much. Right. You've said that Muhammad
has never
>> the hell off my stage. You absolute
robot. You dumb numb bot. Get off the
stage. You're You're incapable of having
a conversation. You have no
self-control, no self-awareness. You
don't belong here. Get off the stage.
Let's see if uh we can get an actual
human on here. Please, Muslims, be
human. Be human. Okay? I know it's tough
when you're in Islam and the amount of
zombie brain rot. I got you. But you're
dealing with a person who, you know, uh
I love you guys and I'm willing to give
you guys chances after chances after
chances. So be a human. Engage. Engage.
Don't be a bot. All right. Yayan.
Yahwan.
>> Hello.
>> Hello. Larry. Are you a Muslim?
>> Of course.
>> Awesome. Would you trust a religion with
corrupted scripture, my brother?
>> Would I trust a religion with corrupted
scripture?
>> Yeah.
>> No.
>> I wouldn't either. So, you would agree
with me that a religion that contains
corrupted scripture is untrustworthy?
>> Yeah. Yes.
>> Awesome. You believe the Torah was
revealed by Allah?
>> Yeah.
>> What happened to it? says that in the
Quran the rabbis they they neglected the
scripture and didn't uphold what they
were commanded to
>> surah 5 verse14
>> so they got corrupted
>> okay hidden neglected
>> all of that what about the zabor the
zabor of David did did that get
>> okay
>> gospel too
>> the endure
>> yeah not the gospel of Luke Matthew Mark
and John
>> yeah the gospel of Jesus
>> which by the way god logic let me ask
you a question ironic like
>> brother please in the middle of Israel.
>> You found four guys with the names of
Mark Matthew.
>> Please stay focused. What's wrong with
you guys? Stay focused.
>> I don't like what was that squirrel.
>> Does that make sense to you?
>> What was that? You know, yeah. You know,
does that make sense to you?
>> Within Islam, you know, uh you know, in
the middle of the desert, you find four
English rabbis to to take care, Mark,
Luke, and the Psalms, and the David. A
squirrel.
>> No, it's not like that.
>> That's That's exactly what just
happened, bro.
>> A monkey. What if you did that?
>> Monkey.
>> You do that.
>> Yeah. Monkey. Yeah, you. Yeah. Look at
the mirror and do that.
>> Uhoh. Monkey.
>> Look at the mirror and do that.
>> Monkey.
>> Yeah, that's what you should do in the
mirror.
>> Goodness. I asked for a human being.
[clears throat]
>> Hey yo, that like What was that? That
was wild. Did y'all see that? How?
They're like androids, man. He was He
was having a a regular talk and then
boom, just squirrel. Like that was crazy
work, man. Crazy crazy work. Caveman
people, man. Precisely. Okay, amen.
People, man. Jay School in the house
says, "You're one of the reasons I
became Christian, man. Glory to God."
Praise God. Keep doing the work,
brother. Also, recently bought a shirt.
Hey, hopefully in five years, I will
become an apologist as well. I've been
studying a lot of your videos. God bless
you, man. Glory to God. Yeah, take the
videos, learn from them, take notes,
adopt the same style that I use in and
engaging, but make it your own. You know
what I'm saying? You're Jay. You're Jay.
So, be yourself and you know, yeah, let
the Lord lead you, man. That's that's
awesome. Glory to God. Glory to God.
Okay, let's see if we can get somebody
normal. That's that's strike two. That's
strike two for for the request of
somebody normal. MJ, how you doing?
>> Hey, peace be upon you, man.
>> Peace be upon you as well. You a Muslim?
>> That's it. Teach you guys how to be more
like Jesus.
>> Okay. Are you a Muslim?
>> Yes.
>> You believe you're like Jesus?
>> I believe that we greet like Jesus. We
eat like Jesus.
>> Are you baptized?
>> We pray like Jesus.
>> What's that?
>> Are you baptized?
>> I'm circumcised.
>> I don't know. Did Jesus get baptized?
>> Yes.
>> I I get baptized five times a day for
Woo.
>> No, you don't. That's That's not
baptism. Baptism is submersion. Being
under put under water, right? So, are
you baptized?
>> What's What is baptism?
>> I just told you.
>> Being submerged under water. So, taking
a bath.
>> Yep. Being sub and then being brought
back up. Are you baptized? Yes or no, my
guy.
>> Does a priest have to do it for me to be
baptized?
>> I just want to know if you're baptized
or not.
>> Not in the in the same sense that you
guys baptism. I take a
>> bath. So, you're not like Jesus. Okay.
Do you when you pray, do you call your
father?
>> Oh, boy.
>> When you pray, do you call God your
father?
>> In the book of Matthew, it says, "And
Jesus fell to his face and prayed." So,
I pray like that.
>> Oh, who do you pray to in that verse?
>> Elohim.
>> He said, "Father, didn't he?" I don't
know what he said in Kaic Greek or
Aramaic or Hebrew.
>> It's pater in Greek. It's Aramaic. It's
in it's it's abba. So he called God his
father in that verse, right?
>> Supposedly some I mean you kick the guy
off.
>> So do you do you pray like that? Do you
call God your father when you pray?
>> Do you greet people with peace be upon
you?
>> Brother, brother, just be simple. Do you
pray?
>> I'm being simple. Do you call God your
father?
>> I'm being simple. I don't eat pork.
Jesus never ate pork. and get off.
>> I greet people with peace be upon you.
>> Off my stage. Strike three, guys. Geez.
The fruit of Islam. Brain rot dumbbots.
Hey, my god. Brain rot dumbbots. Amazing
stuff. Look at that. Pork. No. Children.
Halal. Pork. Haram. Nine-year-old girls.
Halal. All right. Do your thing, man. Do
your thing. Do your thing. Matter of
fact, let me go ahead and get rid of you
like fully. Let's go ahead and block you
since you're requesting up again like a
[__] Don't ever request up on my stage
again. You'll never be here again. Uh,
let's see. Mickey, dang. Was Zacharia
the only person I was able to get a
conversation with over here? What's up?
Oh, yeah. Remember the first Muslim was
good. Ali,
>> what's up, Adam? Would you trust a
religion with corrupted scripture, Adam?
>> It depends. You got to be more specific.
>> I don't think that you got to be It's
very simple. Would you trust a religion
with corrupted scripture?
>> A final revelation or are you referring
to previous scripture?
>> I'm referring to a religion that within
it has corrupted scripture whether its
final scripture was good or not. If it
has any corrupted scripture within the
religion, is that religion trustworthy?
>> So again, if it was the previous
scripture, I feel like that's why God
would reveal additional scripture after.
>> Not what I asked, bro. Not what I asked.
>> Okay, sure. or if it's the previous
scripture, I don't see why that would be
a problem. If you have a final
scripture, you
>> got it. So, your answer is yes, you
would trust a religion that has
corrupted scripture.
>> If the previous scripture is not my
current scripture, like for example, the
Quran is the final revelation. That's my
scripture what I go off of as a Muslim.
It doesn't matter what the
>> Do you know the six do you know the six
principles of Islam?
>> Yeah, of course. I believe in the
scripture. I believe that the original
Torah and the
>> So the scriptures are still So the
scriptures are still yours. All of them,
right?
>> We believe that God revealed them to the
prophets. Yes.
>> Not not just that he revealed them. You
have to believe in them, don't you?
>> Right. And reveal that. Well, we believe
that they were revealed to the prophets.
>> So the Quran is not your only scripture.
The previous scriptures are your
scriptures as well. That's part of your
religion. Right.
>> Right. But the Quran is the authority
over them.
>> You could say that all you want. That's
fine. But they're still your scriptures.
So, would you trust a religion that has
corrupted scripture in it?
>> I mean, like I said, it depends what
you're referring to. You can't just put
make it into a broad vague category and
try to make it seem like, oh, it's
corrupted, so you have to go by what
this says. We have the Quran. We
acknowledge that the Torah was given to
Moses. We acknowledge that the Psalms
were given to David, but we have the
Quran. Our authority is the Quran. So,
that's what we would go off of. It's not
hard. I didn't ask what you would go off
of.
>> If you don't, I'm gonna give you another
chance. You have another opportunity to
answer the question. Oh, yes.
>> Yep.
>> So, so yes, you trust a religion with
corrupted scripture within it.
>> If that's how you want to word it. And
>> it's not just how I want to word it.
It's what the question is. It's what
you're admitting to. You trust a
religion with corrupted scripture in it.
Right.
>> If you want to word it. Okay. So, why
did God give
>> I need I need an affirmation.
>> Okay. But this kind of goes off of what
your question is. Why didn't God just
reveal the Torah? And
>> I need an answer.
>> I already said yeah. I don't know what
else you want.
>> So I need So to be clear,
>> you believe in a religion that has
corrupted scripture, right?
>> If it was the previous scripture, sure.
>> So the answer is yes. Cuz you don't you
don't have to say if it was the previous
scripture. It's a yes or no. Do you
follow a religion that has corrupted
scripture in it? Yes or no?
>> I'm giving you an exact answer. If it's
the
>> previous answer is a yes or a no.
>> Right? But it's not that simple. And you
know that there's there's reasons behind
it.
>> That's fine. You can give me your
reasons. Just answer my question
directly and then you can give your
reasons.
>> Okay? Like I said, we have the Quran. We
do not believe that it's correct.
>> I don't care about what you have. What
the answer is yes or no. Do you follow a
religion with corrupted scripture? Yes
or no?
>> No.
>> Do you see why that that that matters?
So, you could do all that fluff. You can
do all that that crap. When I asked you
when I asked you the direct, Hold on a
second.
>> You tried to pretend like you were
answering my question honestly, but you
wasn't because when I demanded that you
answer it directly, you switched. Now
you're saying no. Do you see why? Do you
see why that was important?
>> But this is your tactic. You know very
well. It's not hard to comprehend what
I'm telling you. It's very hard for me
to comprehend semantics.
>> You You want to know what's hard for me
to comprehend, Adam?
>> You want to force an answer?
>> You want to know what's hard for me to
comprehend? Let me tell you what's hard
for me to comprehend.
>> It's hard for me to comprehend an a yes
no answer.
>> Yes. No. Yes. No. No. Yes. Yes. No. No.
Yes. I didn't say that. No. Yes.
>> You don't want You don't want to
compromise.
>> Yes. No. You do you think that that's
intelligible?
So,
>> let's go over it.
>> This is what I need you to do. If you
want me to understand what you're
saying, what I need you to do is I need
you to be straight up. Be straight up
with me.
>> Stand 10 toes on your belief and your
answer. Don't switch and contradict
yourself two seconds later. That's a
that's the best way you will get me and
the rest of the audience to comprehend
what you're saying.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Are you gonna listen to me?
>> I'll give you another chance because you
said no. You said yes. I'll give you
another chance and I'll I'll you you
have my ear. I promise. But I need you
to answer directly and then give your
reasons. Okay? Do you believe in a
religion with corrupted scripture? Yes
or no?
>> Right? And you're not going to interrupt
me, right? You're going to let me
>> as long as you're direct. If you are
answer me directly and then expound
after you've answered directly, I won't
interrupt you. Yes or no? To answer your
question, do we believe that God's
scripture was corrupted?
>> I didn't ask that.
>> Do you see what you just did there? You
see how you just changed my question?
>> Jesus Christ is the Lord Almighty.
>> What's different?
>> What's different from what I said and
what you said?
>> Okay. I want you to hear the difference.
Do you believe in a religion that is
that has corrupted scripture?
>> Well, yeah.
>> Not that. Do you believe that there are
scriptures that have been corrupted?
That's a different question. So answer
my question and stop playing games with
me or else I'mma move on.
>> Do you believe in a religion that has
corrupted scripture? Yes. No. And then
explain.
>> Yes, we believe that the previous
scriptures were corrupted. And that's
why God gave us the Quran. It's not hard
to understand. Why did God continuously
give revelation prophet after prophet?
Why didn't he just give the Torah and
let that be the only scripture and leave
it at that? Because over time we know
that people they go astray. So obvious
>> this is on YouTube. You have every
opportunity to watch your clipback.